it's not uncommon in Counter-Strike for
certain players to become known for a
very specific
thing it could be their prowess with a
particular weapon the mastering of a
deadly mechanic or even a single Galaxy
brain to play bring more this is so
smart oh this is huge don't just
throwing a maid into the corner just as
the ball is gonna go off gonna go down
now while some of these traits are based
on hard data others are unquantifiable
mythological even for instance we can
easily see to the decimal point screams
unbelievable headshot percentage but
sometimes even when you look at the
stats something like Arts signature
aggression needs to be seen before it
can be believed but this is again just
art doing art things aggression into mid
a quick headshot onto moose he's even
gonna go jumping into the windows but be
careful because me who I'm waiting on
the other side but of course R wins that
battle as well technically traded no he
can't art is on an absolute tear leaving
just two players standing and what just
ace it come on just clear them all out
there's only one man left in your way
and Art's gonna do the job in similar
fashion there's another player who has a
fabled proficiency that is somewhat
difficult to describe I am of course
talking about Spencer heco Martin and
his many miracle-grade clutches that
bomb plants already been happening for
quite a while here so hiko and Sean has
a good Kill from hika but they realize
Dupree is still in there somewhere
they're gonna try and go for it here
they want to go all in Eco comes in with
another kill and back to a 20 to that
bomb so far take they gotta move quick
right now they're going for it the
diffuse is already happening hey girl
are you kidding me he's gonna go for it
they win the round he go fix up a triple
A Cloud Nine win it what but what if I
told you that it was all a lie that all
of the praise he goes received over the
years for his magnificent clutches has
been undeserved
that all this time
hiko
has been baiting well you'd probably say
nice meme because he go being a Bader
has been a bit of a running joke for
years now but ever since he made the
jump from Counter-Strike to valorent and
switched from playing entry to well Sova
his Intel oriented playstyle has been
put under the microscope and with
hundred thieves struggling coming out of
valorin's first competitive year the
so-called jokes have devolved into
criticism and sometimes even vitriol he
goes just the biggest bidder of all time
so what exactly is the truth is the
lasting Legacy of one of nacs's most
storied Pro players that of a clutch
artist or just that of a masturbator he
activated
hey guys so before we dive into the
great debate please like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications if we hit 2 million Subs
before the end of the month I will be
giving away my fabled gun Year to one
lucky view wait what the [__] I didn't
sign up for this all right so when it
comes to North American Counter-Strike
there are very few Players whose names
carry the same clout and historical
significance as hiko of course this is
mostly due to the fact that he's been
around for so damn long and because he's
repeatedly melted our minds over the
course of his career and now to one
versus two and heco he's something of an
expert in this field looking for a
little bit more he wants them to Peak he
wants to see if they can get one more
chance to rest our input position hiko
fakes it once gonna go up for a bit of a
fight line with 20 seconds left soon he
won't be able to fake it they're going
to be too close he's rapping around he's
not looking for the fake he's looking
for the kill gonna get one more in here
15 seconds jumping up and shooting he's
gonna go for the fight he goes
one versus three and there it is but
we're not here today to Ogle heco's most
iconic plays or mourn his unfortunate
catalog of truly cursed happenstances or
wax poetic about his obvious value to
the foundation of Na Esports we're here
to find out if heco is in fact a filthy
no good Vader and in order to do that we
need to establish something that will
prove very valuable over the course of
this video and that thing
context throughout the majority of hiko
Cs go career he's been classified as a
lurker a player who typically operates
away from the rest of their team picking
off rotating enemies creating and or
capitalizing on space and gaining map
info but in being a lurker you often put
yourself in situations where you need to
be the hero and over and over again hiko
would prove that he was that guy you're
not that guy pal trust me you're not
that guy no I'm no I'm saying he was
that guy trust me now again as we've
seen so many times before it's down to
heco but against four is it really
possible we do have a few players quite
tagged up here from Luminosity so he
could definitely not going down without
a fight oh wow there's a first boss
right he could gets a double there's
still two players left they got no
Health on them 13 and three hiku
creeping around the site now there's
still time to oh my goodness how does it
top of this hiko is typically sight
anchor on CT meaning that he would often
hold an aggressive position on a site
and as such be the last to rotate now
this wasn't an absolute of course as
with most players it depended on the map
and who they were up against
but when heco did anchor
it was for good reason because let me
tell you facing down a lone heco on B
wasn't always the easiest task here it
is the only caveat that they have for
that strategy and that's nothing is it
gonna be the classic win to close it out
on an eco eco with the 3K make it four
with the five seven now the thing about
lurkers and anchors is they're often the
last ones left alive if things go
sideways and sometimes when you weren't
playing with your team because it's what
your position required and they all die
without you
you you do run the risk of being labeled
a Vader you know the FPS slur that aptly
describes scum of the earth teammates
who regardless of the situation waits
till all of their teammates are dead to
mop up the mess for their own personal
Glory
stop baiting your mates
now it just so happens that because our
boy Spencer was both an anchor and a
lurker he usually was the last man
standing and from that recognizable
pattern the hiko is a Bader meme was
born now of course like all things
spammed at nauseum in twitch chat and
plastered across the HL TV forums it was
totally harmless and all in good fun
but as hiko sort of fell out of the
spotlight following his departure from
Team Liquid in 2017. the meme died out
and with it any real debates about its
legitimacy what's more over time the
lurking role as a whole sort of fell out
of favor in CS go on top of that hiko
was getting older unfortunately for him
building a CS go team in North America
was no easy task so in the spring of
2020 hiko took his talents to valorant
where understandably he would be one of
the first major signings for Riot's CS
inspired shooter our first player ever
signed to our valoran team Tico now
anyone who watched valarante back then
knows that the first iteration of the
hundred thieves roster was interesting
to say the least let's just say that it
was hiko with four Pub G pros and hiko
was playing entry on raise because a he
was cracked and had a super High
sensitivity and tons of experience
and B
because again he was the only
Counter-Strike player and that went
about as well as you'd expect this round
maybe could be going for a hundred
thieves but venerated keeps on putting
together some shots Corey at the back of
the gong he's going to be good for one
raucous gets a kill outside and FaZe
Clan stay alive in this competition
eventually hundred thieves clued into
the fact that in the early days of
valorant the recipe for Success was in
fact Cs and after the team acquired
Nitro steel Asuna and dicey they
established themselves as a force to be
reckoned with in North America they have
to find a way out of the situation but
it's getting worse and worse and who
better than hiko to look to seal the
deal here in this Grand finals as colors
tries he does all that he can but is
simply not enough against a hundred
thieves a hundred thieves they've done
it they are your first strike North
America Champions now part of 100
thieves's early success was old tahiko
making a roll switch since he no longer
needed to be the entry hiko was able to
lock in Sova and use that big brain of
his to get Intel lurk and clutch when
needed of course it wasn't long after
reprising said roll that the baiting
memes began to resurface if hiko was
playing you know the twitch chat was
spamming the all too classic copy pasta
my name is hiko forehead I'm a Bader
forehead I'll meet you at the bomb site
forehead a little bit later now to be
fair most of the comments were just
jokes or old CS fans teaching young
impressionable Valor and fans how to
troll but once hundred thieves started
to post mixed results those jibes became
a little more serious who needs to go
out of 100 thieves
um
probably dicey
or maybe like
he goes just the biggest Invader of all
time you can all be kicked I know they
won't be kicked but that's why they
won't win now almost immediately hiko
and his teammates laughed it off
reminding Twitter of the iconic copy
pasta but because not all Valor and
kitties were in on the joke and some
actually agreed with chemicals criticism
hiko decided to address the clip on
stream the last thing you want to do
when you're like an upcoming Pro like
still kind of a nobody but your your
team is doing really well
um
is attack
anybody at another team
like that's like the last thing you want
to do trust me I've I've learned through
my mistakes I've definitely had my fair
share of doing what he did when I was
younger I think it's the wrong way to
deal with stuff and again I don't really
care
if someone calls me a Vader because I am
a baiter I'll be the first to admit I'll
be the first to tell you I'm a Vader but
it's just the way that he said it was
very like I said it was very hate-filled
it was very like his tone was came off
as very
not good now before you start saying
would hiko himself just said he's a
Vader I'm going to offer you some more
of that magical intoxicating ingredient
mentioned earlier called context first
of all hiko plays a lot of Sova an agent
that typically is selected by aggressive
players so instead of fragging out he
could be found droning or lining up
shocked Arts while his teammates were
engaging in battle it's literally his
job to stay alive and gather Intel for
his roster what's more if there is one
player you want last alive in North
America
it's ego
I don't know I'm like playing Super
selfish
I'm just naughty secondly I need to
explain something that is long overdue
there is a difference between baiting
and trading and that difference for the
most part
is intent baiting is when you purposely
let your team die so you can pop in
right after to secure the easy kill when
the enemy is reloading repositioning or
rotating but if you communicate with
your team and play off their engagements
while putting in an effort to clear
corners and hold angles you're trading
unfortunately for hiko that distinction
didn't seem to matter to his haters
Clips would routinely make the rounds
painting him to be the filthy no good
Vader that they wanted him to be but
since it's heco we're talking about
usually the evidence of him baiting was
overshadowed by a ridiculous clutch
there's only one man left standing is
heco and Hayes does not care he wants to
shoot everybody in the face and here
comes the late like three from Waddell
surely not right silence sure there you
go Eco gets one on to Wardell he's got
the spike he's got 30 seconds so he has
some time he also has the ultimate the
problem is you have to somehow sneak
onto the site get the spike down and
then stay alive long enough to be able
to use your Hunter series he's got no
freaking way hiko does this again he
drops things down to a 1v1 Taps looking
for a swing he spotted Cutler so he has
a great idea don't worry
Diego does it again are you kidding me
now I say usually because it didn't work
out that way all the time and all it
really takes is one out of context clip
for people to get really riled up
dude I thought I just shot my knives at
Spencer because he's just not going out
to make matters worse 100 thieves's
downward spiral continued over the
course of 2021. in 2022 things reached a
Tipping Point after a now Infamous match
against the guard this is what's gonna
push the guard maybe to this win two
more kills remaining for this team Rico
and Echo make it only he go will it be a
Flawless to finish it off a prime gaming
Flawless for the guard does get that
wrong
but still no more shock darts instead
Eco just going in he actually goes for
the fake
one person coming up from cat there goes
the drop from Eccles Trident Valen all
getting killed a 4v1 a statement from
the guard
13-0 over a hundred thieves after
bombing out of qualifiers for Iceland
even hundred thieves's most loyal fans
began to scapegoat hiko but things went
from bad to worse when yet another clip
went viral of hiko ostensibly baiting
I mean he goes
two
weeks
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay even I will admit that that does
look pretty bad if you were a heco hater
you jumped all over this but without
even being asked Ethan one of hiko's
teammates came to his defense oh the 200
clip of hiko and spawn bro bro y'all are
weird Doug he's literally he said I'm
holding you right and I was like all
right and I'm just delaying they just
never swung right and when they did
swing right they flashed him so he had
to get pushed up spawn listen if this
was a plot Lobby then sure you could say
that that Reina was baiting you people
do it all the time it's actually
instinctual for a lot of solo healers
and a pretty bad habit if you ask me but
at the pro level unless we hear the
comms or someone from the team comes out
and says something explicitly we really
have no way of knowing it would be
insane to assume that a top level team
isn't communicating and playing off each
other it's even sillier to assume that
if he go was truly baiting all this time
that he never faced any consequences
it's also important to note that
sometimes when consciously executed
baiting can be a good thing
one enemy remaining
now look you could probably make the
argument that hiko's playstyle be it
grounded in trading or baiting
isn't exactly what hundred thieves
needed for whatever reason the results
just weren't there and the team just
wasn't jiving but were they really gonna
part ways with the guy who's been on the
team since the very beginning it would
be a difficult decision to make but
thankfully hiko made the call himself
I'll always miss competing I'm gonna
always miss like all the people I've
made friends with going to events
traveling but at the end of the day like
it's gonna allow me to do something that
I've always wanted to do but I've never
had the time to actually do it so to
make a long story short is heco a Bader
no at least not in the way that the
average player might Define it it's safe
to say that it hasn't been hiko's secret
career-long plan to let his teammates
die so he can pull off these insane are
you kidding me grade clutches he would
never hang out people to drive that's
just not the type of person or player
that he is was and presumably ever will
be he was always ready to help to any
player he could take any spot I think
he's one of the greatest teammate and I
think he's one of the smartest guy he
goes mythologized heroics shouldn't be
reduced to a joke at his expense they
should be revered as a testament to not
only his skill but his legacy he might
never have obtained CS Go's most
prestigious silverware and his success
in valorant was sadly short-lived but
what he gave us instead was 14 years of
legendary individual moments of
Brilliance and I personally wouldn't
trade
that for anything shadeoff's good for
wine we go trades one down oh just
narrowly not able to get the second
Pitch again he's able to get a second
one heco 24 Health Ronnie passes
Chronicle has plenty of Health Chronicle
on the tap
that bro it's not fake he's gotta get it
to happen swings out he gets four he
gets the Red Bull clutch
you a lot you'll you'll really get
you'll really enjoy the fact that when I
tweeted at the official Rainbow Six
Siege Twitter account about how they
wouldn't follow me
the official Siege Twitter account just
responded to me with emotional damage
follow me back they just responded with
emotional damage that's it
[Music]